it's going to be a good [ __ ] week
what's happening with you tarzan nothing
i got a great weekend with you in san
diego oh my god then 26 with a [ __ ]
ninja turtle straight up hey everyone
loves you oh my gosh you're 20 [ __ ]
six years old but it's really nice
awesome shirt i don't care what you
remember
yeah yeah i'm sure you doing what's up
rick man
good how are you so you're going to
houston this weekend smooth
old school improv yep
if my ex does come i have something to
give your boy doug benson on thursday
yeah
that's fine yeah yeah i had to take it
what the [ __ ]
go back to acetone get some good food i
miss it i miss it i miss texas in
general it's been a while but definitely
houston i miss you you're not going to
austin and they don't book you in austin
yeah you know
i i have to do all those bookings and so
it's just like i have to go reach out to
everybody and do all that and it's just
it's so much work joey you know how it
is
it's
[ __ ] yeah you've really been working
the stand-up angle i'm really proud of
you i see you out there every night
you're swinging
and that's all it is the swing is
paradise though yeah i'm kind of over
the la
la doing doing so much here though does
that ever get better because like the la
doing ellie audiences just kind of
i don't know just sad it's very sad life
well that's why you go on the road
because then you break it up and you
have to you learn how to work the la
audiences and you work you learn how to
work the different road rooms that you
work you know yeah la burns me up la
i burnt down in l.a uh maybe eight or
nine years ago
for two years i did it against my
[ __ ] will
until i said that's it
you know and i would go to the improv
periodically
the laugh factory wouldn't have me and i
stopped going to the store so it was
like very uh
you know
i
i don't mind it now yeah i don't mind it
because i go down on tuesdays thursdays
and saturdays
i do a spot i get in the car and get the
[ __ ] out of there you know i walk around
the store looking like a rapist i'm too
old to be over there at the store it's a
bunch of young girls and young kids you
know
you're standing there with [ __ ] gray
hair looking like a dope
i know when i first got to the store
they'd be dudes with gray hair i get
pissed off they go the [ __ ] home right
are they gonna happen you know what i'm
saying
you're not doing the spot go home it's
not the same is it it's not really
anymore because i do remember where that
was the whole thing like no you're
trying to get into tv you're trying to
get on uh carson and it was all about
the young kids and then
nowadays it seems like i mean there's a
lot of comics that are starting at
35 they're becoming a comic for the
first time 30 you know
it seems like it's a little different
with that nowadays because tv doesn't
seem as important or
is it i don't know
well
it's a young man's game i mean
everything is a young man's game
baseball
football i mean you're not going to walk
on the football field 44 and say give me
the [ __ ] ball they'll kill you
but
that's the advantage you have as a comic
that you could always work in that field
you could evolve to a writer you could
evolve to so many different things
as far as the comedy story
you want me to sit here and tell you
that i thought i'd be slinging jokes on
the road at 52
i had different plans but those weren't
the plans that i would happen but guess
what i'm still at the store
people still give their lives to be at
the [ __ ] store to be at the store
four nights a week is huge two nights a
week that's you're in the game you're in
the [ __ ] game okay if you're not at
the store you're not in the [ __ ] game
if you're not the improv you're not
really in the game if you're not the
live factor
you're not really in the game but when
you're at the store there's something
about the store that you're in the
[ __ ] game you know uh
listen man the story to me is exactly
the same
people go up
people bomb
some people stay
and let the miracle [ __ ] happen and
some people tap out and go back to
wherever the [ __ ] they're from with an
excuse on la is filled with [ __ ] and
scientologists who want to suck your
dick and take you in a cave and electric
you you
whatever you know i it's always great
the rooms i'm working now i don't run
into the bitter comics that left that
way
but you go on the sea circuit and the b
circuit oh boy you're gonna get them you
live in l.a [ __ ] you man you know
a bunch of [ __ ] losers out there you
got to know people to get on stage you
don't have to know nobody got to be
funny bro you got to be funny and
maneuver yourself and go out at night
and meet people and by meeting those
people that you're performing with
you'll elevate up
right or wrong redman i agree i mean i
i'm so lucky to be able to do the ice
house every friday you know do the death
squad show there and one of my favorite
things is mixing up new comics with old
comics i you know
it's so there's so many comics in this
town that i don't know you you look at
half these advertisements for like
flappers or ice house or and you look at
the lineup i mean i don't know any of
these people sometimes and that just
shows you how many people are in this
game that we play and it's really weird
when you hanging out the comedy store it
seems like we have
all the the number one comics hanging
out around us but then you wonder if
that same kind of environment happens
everywhere and and you know
because there's thousands of comics
right and we just happen to hang out
with a good small group of 20 to 30 that
we see on a regular basis but what's
what about those other thousand you know
it's it's very interesting because uh i
met somebody the other day and he's been
doing comedy for 15 years uh and he's
been doing it in illinois and now he
opens up uh for doug stanhope brett uh
thompson uh but you know he's one of the
nice guys nicest guys he's got a family
he's got a daughter in uh college and
everything like that and and uh he just
moved to los angeles at i forget how old
he's like he's like a little older than
me i think or
but he just moved out to los angeles to
try it to try to make it at 40 and i was
just like you know what that's [ __ ]
amazing i want you on a death squad so i
want to mix you with this 22 year old
that's that that's only been doing
comedy for a week and it's so fun to see
and to help people as much as possible
in los angeles and in comedy all the
time but uh it's it's amazing that that
people
try like last doing it when you see
somebody that's like i've been doing it
for 15 years and you still see them
doing spots you know
five-minute spots you know here and
there and i'm like how what keeps you
going at this man because this is a very
sad life you know
what's the success
what does success mean to you
as a comic as a as a [ __ ] electrician
all right so you're an electrician in
[ __ ] columbus ohio
after four years six years you become a
journeyman so i put you at let's say
you're a [ __ ] up you miss work
you got fired for six months
at 30 you're 28 you're a journeyman if
you get a [ __ ] high school and go to
your classes at night
then
when you're like 32 you get a little
serious you meet this girl
she likes to [ __ ] suck but she also
likes to go away on the weekends that
costs money that that
16.50 you're making isn't gonna work so
now you have options
you gonna go work for a different
company or you can start your own
[ __ ] company
you know you have all these options
and wherever that option takes you
wherever you go with it that's where
your success is
are you with me like that's what you
pick there's comedians that start in
colorado
that have no intention in their mind
ever doing a movie
a tv show or being in [ __ ] los
angeles
they do stand up
to do stand up
and they become feature acts local
feature acts and they get involved with
uh
athletics like they do all the [ __ ] like
let's say you're clean you get involved
with the [ __ ] lakers man
if you like basketball you go down they
do a couple free [ __ ] benefits let
them check you out do a benefit they pay
you 500 a thousand now you're doing all
the laker functions my friend ron does
that rod long does that in seattle you
know rod wong would not move down here
one of the funniest guys i ever worked
with he had
he was probably making 150 grand as a
comedian in seattle had a house two kids
a wife smoked dope all day
and he added money to his income when he
went on the road he took pictures
and he developed the pictures and he
paint them in
and he put him on ebay and sell him and
somebody made a profit and some he
didn't
but that was his happiness
you know we were talking about our
friend
jay
and how
he was struggling here what's he getting
one [ __ ] spot a week right he's
living on somebody's couch you know he
had a breakup with somebody who he loved
you know he gets dick he's a good
looking guy i mean you mean [ __ ] huh he
gets [ __ ] he gets [ __ ] so
he's a good looking guy uh we're talking
about a friend of ours jason and he uh
is a great guy funny as [ __ ] when he's
on he has a weird different look on
things and a way of writing but you
could tell the personality change when
he [ __ ] drinks you want to strangle
them but you'll love them so much in the
daytime it's like living with dracula
you love him so much in the daytime you
don't want to kill him at night when
he's dracula when he gets three drinks
in he tries to call you out and he tries
to just be mean to you and you're like j
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you you know
but you know he's a great guy but he's
surrounded
his friend he's seeing that his friends
are moving forward
and he's moving backwards you know how
bad of a feeling that is
her over there you know how bad i'm
feeling
you and three editors go to emerson
college you all come out here
two of you guys are working our editors
and you're still an assistant editor how
bad would you [ __ ] yeah be terrible
same thing you know when it takes some
guys six years
it takes some guys two years to become
another it's just the luck of the
[ __ ] cards but somewhere along the
line he gets [ __ ] hammered
he loses his uh compass
and he disappears for six months to get
clean and sober and he'll come back the
best jason he's ever [ __ ] been yeah
it's gonna be amazing to see that place
is heavy on people
this place is [ __ ] heavy
the people you see in la now
you're gonna see a third of them in five
years
and then in seven years it's going to be
a complete new social media when they're
going to be on them and they're going to
want to request you to a friend you're
going to go
what happened to that person
because you see so many people come and
go here it's like a [ __ ]
carousel of people here that are gonna
come over and take over this [ __ ]
town they got the idea for a movie they
got the idea for a reality show they've
been doing comedy for two years i got
this you you guys are suckers you've
been working for 10 years we got the
answers they come they last a year and
they disappear
then you bump into them
and they'll tell you how uh
their grandfather died and then they
come back to take care of the family and
the house
you [ __ ] bury grandpa you sell the
couch
you [ __ ] you close the house up you
move some people in there you come back
to l.a that's what a comic does
somebody who's not a comic just gives up
and that's the excuse right there was a
death in the family or that was
this or something else happened
and they go back to where they [ __ ]
started from but comedy has no way it's
listen i came out here when i was 32 red
men did i have a dream i don't know
[ __ ] dream the reason why i'm doing
what i'm doing is because i lasted
that's it i lasted
again back to richard getting off and
gentlemen
i had nowhere else to go
it seems like
this place
is a lot crazier
in general though like uh you know i
mean i got roofied the other day
where does that happen everywhere to a
guy no who ever is a guy everywhere
how do you know you got roofied
uh
i was at the improv and it was dead so
i'm like you know what i'm just gonna go
home and didn't even have a drink at the
improv it was one of those nights
and i'm driving by jumbo's clown room
and uh i i was like oh my friend works
there i'll go and see if she's there
and uh
i had my had a drink
saw david arquette there i was like oh
david's [ __ ] up
and then uh saw two other guys that i
knew that was like a girl's ex-boyfriend
and her friend i was like oh those guys
whatever
then i had went to get my second drink
took like two sips and then like
everything just started like getting
real closed up you know like in a tunnel
like my vision got kind of weird i'm
like oh [ __ ] something's not right
my car is parked right in front of me
that happens to me twice a week i know
but i mean second drink no weed or
anything no edibles uh
so i go out my car's right out front so
i'm like you know i'm gonna go have a
cigarette go sit in my car for a bit
something's not right i don't feel good
so i put my drink down
went out to my car sat down in the
passenger seat and it got so bad where i
had to close my eyes because everything
was spinning so much and the next thing
i know i woke up like an hour and a half
two hours later and i'm just in my car
and i'm perfectly fine now but i feel
really muscle relaxed like just muscle
relaxers
and i guess i drove home i don't
remember but i remember feeling fine
next day the whole day i felt like i was
a muscle relaxer so i felt really like
oh what like kind of like uh i had
tripped on acid the night before or
something you know and i had that hank
acid hangover or something it was bad
dude
and uh the one thing that i didn't
expect though it was like
it really [ __ ] with you though like
like i didn't expect that part like the
part where i'm like holy [ __ ] dude if i
was not in the right place at the right
you know where i could go to my car what
would have happened you know where would
i end up i pretty much got drugged like
in a movie where somebody drugs you with
the
the the tissue on your nose you know
chloroform or whatever like that's
pretty much the same thing that happened
to me but i was luckily in a public
place where i could get to my car real
quick so then i start getting into like
this post-traumatic like what the [ __ ]
happened who did that why would they do
that to me you know is that somebody i
know is this like crazy fan is this a
stalker of a girl that i used to [ __ ] i
i mean half my ex-girlfriends have
boyfriends that want to kill me you know
and i mean i have one girl right now
ex-girlfriend that her current boyfriend
is dating sent out letters to joe rogan
acting like a fan of the show trying to
get me fired like you should really fire
him and he's a horrible person and blob
and it's like seven emails that he just
he's spending long time days like just
trying to get me fired
you know so it it [ __ ] with me though
like that you [ __ ] torment these
girls you put them through hell
you make them clean your apartment suck
your dick eat your [ __ ]
they end up [ __ ] doing porn or
[ __ ] moving to memphis and having a
kid
that they're gonna hate you you know you
put them through [ __ ] torture and
then you get rid of them like you know
how many chicks you you [ __ ] torment
since i've known you 10 of them
do you want to know the worst thing that
just happened recently no i know there's
always something let me ask you this
before i won the roof you said okay
since i know you how many times you've
been roofied once
no you've been roofied a couple what
well you roofied me by being doing what
you do to poor flying jewellery
that's not roofie
a roof is when i wake up next year with
a robot [ __ ] he just doesn't remember
that no i would never [ __ ] know that
i would never you have a closet in there
that he doesn't he's not allowed to go
into and then he went into it the other
day and he had flashbacks and i just sit
down on this couch he's gonna be
followed by that [ __ ] fly he's gotta
fly i killed the fly i was really
excited i didn't yeah his cousin's in
the room watching you right now getting
ready to [ __ ] go in there
since i'm knowing that you've been
roofied what like eight times no i
haven't she got back coke you got a bad
[ __ ] mushroom and i've never been
repeating you had a [ __ ]
mushrooms they made you see oh no i
overdosed on mushrooms but that wasn't
me
the ambulance showed up on the 101 well
that's because i had heart like a panic
attack from smoking weed you called the
ambulance on the 101 not on the 101 it
was on sunset but i i've caught the
airplanes on myself like two or three
times
but there's a reason tell them the
reason some people don't think
when i was younger i used to have heart
problems and i thought i was constantly
having a heart attack oh i thought it
was from like drugs or getting too high
or something well no i mean when i get
high oh i start thinking about my heart
like oh my heart's not pounding right
and stop then i start just freaking
myself out but
three times since i was 15 someone
that's not bad uh i got to tell you this
crazy [ __ ] up story this is almost is
this what happened this week this
happened a couple of weeks this happened
a while ago
just say i don't want to put the times
right so i've talked to you about rub
maps before which is this massage parlor
search thing where you can uh search for
paula and i went and looked at it oh you
did oh my god it's [ __ ] it's crazy
the the people who write comments on
there
it's great i read it like it's a book i
i look forward to your reviews
it's yelp for a hand job yeah it's rub
maps like what does it say maps so it
tells you where to go yeah you pretty
much go in there and go where you live
and it shows you all the places around
you and then you can read reviews and
like some places give hand jobs some
people places are at full sex some
places it's just if you want anal sex
some places is if you want a guy dressed
up as a girl you know it's
and it's just all around us like every
if you if you start looking at massage
parlors there's massage parts everywhere
you go there's like one every block it's
almost like three times the amount of
starbucks so i talked about this on the
joe rogan podcast and uh
and uh
this guy heard it and he on a business
trip went uh out and withdrew some money
and got it
uh got sex i guess and then uh when he
came back home his uh fiancee i mean
they've been dating for seven years
they're about to get married uh saw it
uh what he did on on the bank account
statement or whatever like that
confronted him about it
and uh they got divorced uh because of
him hearing about rub maps for me now
all the woman came looking for you
so this out of nowhere this girl
contacted me and she was like uh i
really you know i really think you're
great let's go out for a drink and have
some food and i'm like oh she's just a
fan but she's very hot
and so i went out to dinner with her and
the whole time she's taking she's like
i'm snapchatting and taking photos and
then later we get drunk at the comedy
store and she's snapchatting and then
later we're you know in the hotel room
we're snapchatting what do you think
she's doing
i thought she was just sitting [ __ ]
funny photos snapchat no she sent them
to her [ __ ] legs yeah that's right so
then when i dropped her off at the hotel
room she's like oh by the way this is
you know we're about to get married to
ruin my life blah blah blah uh our
marriage is now over or whatever and
she's just showing me the conversation
it's like hey i'm hanging out guess who
i'm hanging out with it's me like doing
the peace sign with the margarita and
then uh he's like wait where are you are
you what is that [ __ ] red band is red
band in town and then it's like the next
one's at the comedy store and he goes
wait you're in los angeles what the [ __ ]
are you doing so then it ends with me
like uh she's just like uh throw your
[ __ ] at me because it's another thing i
talk about like she had to listen to the
joe rogan experience in the morning uh
in the car at night every single second
he made her listen to it so he ended up
hating joe or she ended up just like i
hate joe i don't want to hear about joe
anymore but uh like like she thought the
funniest revenge would be to [ __ ] me and
it's at the end i'm like spider-man her
tits because she's heard me talk about
spider-man before
did you take a picture of this and send
it to them she she goes hey
i want to take video of you uh
spider-man in my tits i think that's
that would be hilarious i was so wasted
i was like [ __ ] yeah let's do that
no wonder he wants to kill you that's
right that's amazing that's going to
shoot you someone he might have been the
one that roofing me
why would they [ __ ] root for you
i don't know but it's crazy what you
were talking about earlier how if they
roofie or they follow you to the [ __ ]
car
what oh brother about how like uh
like you asked if you need tv
and like you kind of forget what like
things get normal i guess
and like i was i was on facebook today
you know we put out yt that you were the
priest three years ago today huh like
three years ago like we put out one this
week it's either you or the priest
i remember i remember because i posted a
picture it went like number one on
itunes that day and i posted a picture i
was i remember i was at that stupid
editing job hating my life
and i like that cd went number one i was
like wow that's so awesome and it's been
three years it just [ __ ] gets [ __ ]
crazy
how long it's been
i don't know i got high and i thought
about it that's great you got torment
before i hang out who's still renting
this [ __ ] kicked in man i'm pretty
[ __ ]
that's what it's supposed to do if we do
that story i would start started feeling
a sweat drop go down
because we don't want to be high you eat
edibles because no that wasn't that was
snoop doggo g or whatever you gave me
yesterday
that [ __ ] killed you yeah oh my god
that came on strong yesterday that that
that joint didn't come on strong
yesterday for you always comes out
strong that's why he keeps him open i
think you smoke like this comes on weak
i [ __ ] get it because it knocks me to
my [ __ ] death
when i go into that place
they got some nice looking girls in that
place
that sunset herbal got some great
looking women great girls too i love all
the girls now but the guy usually comes
out the mexican
i ask him what he's got in the back and
he usually comes out with a chunk of
something good and he had that snoop oh
gee oh my god
me and lee got [ __ ] up the other day
in san diego
one wanted to eat everything
lee loves bad restaurants too
you and him should hang out a lot i
don't like bad restaurants i like going
to yelp and he gets me super stoned
so i want to eat and he just
i understand why you do it but you
didn't want to go anywhere but a block
from the restaurant like i ended up
going last night to go get those tacos i
wanted like eight minutes away and
you're just like if i can't see it from
the hotel then it's not going to i got a
brian's 24.
that restaurant that's right where you
guys are at the american comedy club
yeah right next door brian's 24 it's
open 24 hours a day they have everything
like waffles fried chicken hamburgers
tacos that's great
it's a great place you never go there
they got everything that scares me
yeah but then we ended up going
somewhere and you hated it it was
[ __ ] horrific
it was [ __ ] horrific
and it's like one of those places where
they blast the music and
they have coffee and they have [ __ ]
dessert and all these gentiles have
slippers and sun hats
and the [ __ ] tuna was horrific it was
drier than [ __ ]
and that multi-grain bread was even
[ __ ] drier they didn't toast it they
didn't put a tomato on it not a lick of
mayonnaise nothing just gave it to me
like a [ __ ]
like a prisoner in [ __ ] uh
cuba what's that place
you're going to tell them about animal
being though just dry [ __ ] tuna it
was horrible horrible
went to the mexican place the one day we
had the ceviche chained up man you like
ceviche yeah i just got i just figured
out what it was recently that's all
right it's just raw fish with [ __ ]
whatever amount of gasoline and mexican
tequila
that's one i can't get used to her mom
makes it but it just what do they put on
it they should just shrimp
and it's still pretty good but it's like
they they put it in raw and they let it
marinate for a couple days so the
texture's a little bit off
from what i'm used to so that's like the
one thing that i i'm not used to yet
with her
she made shrimp today oh my god it was
so good
good just garlic sauteed shrimp a little
bit of rice you're just gonna eat
mexican food till your [ __ ] head
blows off why not why not mexican oh my
god no no that's all he wanted to eat he
couldn't [ __ ] he wouldn't shut the
[ __ ] up about
christina it's only a 10 minute walk get
the [ __ ]
then you got to walk [ __ ] back with
your tacos and your stomach full [ __ ]
you
how long it's a 10 minute walk [ __ ] you
there's something right around the
[ __ ] corner yeah that tuna was right
around the corner yeah mediocre [ __ ]
tacos and [ __ ] oh no there were more
stop stop that's like a mexican design a
[ __ ] area there everything's [ __ ]
god's they give you those small shrimp
from a can what do you think you're
dealing with dog leave me alone
leave me alone i i don't even need to go
there i know what they give you in that
area you did have a good uh
a good thought that we were gonna get
barbecue and we didn't go in because
like i couldn't smell it oh jesus christ
why would a barbecue with three people
in there in san diego who would [ __ ]
even think about going to barbecue in
san diego you're going there just to get
sick the brisket's a week and a half old
not to mention i'm going to h-town on
[ __ ] friday who the [ __ ] are you
kidding me bam that's how they invented
the [ __ ] brisket i'm gonna go to
chewie's and
bibos where what's that might go to the
bible yeah you get that cheese plate
that fried cheese skillet you guys
disgusting that's definitely not it's a
fried cheese plate yeah you gotta go to
this place bieber's what is it it's it's
just [ __ ]
it's this big greek thing it's cheese oh
i think i've seen that they like let it
on fire yeah yes oh [ __ ] i saw that on
uh like the food network or something
just sit there and [ __ ] come all over
yourself when they look on fire people
hate on diners drive-ins and dives they
hit on the host for that show i love
that show especially when i'm high oh my
god do you have a deep belly button lee
i do have you ever come to it and then
not like taking the come out of it and
found it like weeks later not weeks i
take a shower every day but yeah
probably no no you can still come in
your belly button and just seal it off
like they seal jesus in that cage
and then go back in there like two weeks
and find the [ __ ] your belly button a
lot no i haven't done it since i was
like [ __ ] 18 but when i was 18 i come
in my belly button just lock it down
like melt like my belly melt like wax
over it to seal it in there disgusting
disgusting did you just sniff your yeah
i mean because that's something like i
literally never really dig in there but
once i pulled out a like it it i guess
was dried coming it smelled like eggs it
was [ __ ] gross so i wonder if you
ever had that happen to you no
no
i haven't
that's [ __ ] up i do
a lot of people like i never came in a
sock i always just come and then it's
just on the blanket i don't i've never
had like a tissue next to the bed or
that's something just come on the
blanket laying and finagle with it for
two i go to the next side yeah i what
happens when you roll on that when you
roll the knocker on that one what do you
do
i don't do multiple times before i go to
bed do you are you stuck in the middle
no i do i do on one side and you go to
the other side and go to sleep but what
do you do the next night and then it's
dry and you lay on top because you don't
do your sheets like two weeks i know i
do it every week because paula comes
over comes but paula don't come over
those sheets sit there until they turn
[ __ ] gray and yellow yeah like once a
week i bet here's one of those
apartments where you walk and you just
smell the calm the dry comedy just from
his [ __ ] bed no he's disgusting when i
was single when he was single yeah yeah
when he was single i had to check on the
couch
he would go in that room and bang
himself up that he was i would see him
in the morning his eyes would be [ __ ]
she'd be sleeping on the couch a little
undies on little pubic heads popping out
of her [ __ ] and he's sitting there i
gotta go to bed [ __ ] a [ __ ]
do something [ __ ] cosby the girl on
the couch and then they found nothing
she moved down she [ __ ] eight guys and
she went back
guys how many she [ __ ] i don't know
four
at that job don't tell me you told me
yourself now you don't [ __ ] know why
you're like oh yeah not eight like two
or three four
okay the dude the other dude then she
left them for the do with the yacht
that she cheated on him remember
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you no
you're still trapped
you can't say nothing in front of me it
goes right into the mental [ __ ] block
and i save it for later
i am so [ __ ] up right now
those were that was that triple tails
that's what got me on shop because we
had the green horn and then we had a
piece of the star it's hard to focus
it's like 80 milligrams
we should eat a piece of the style [ __ ]
it man i'm gonna be [ __ ] up anyways
i don't know it looks like a big thing
of sushi like tuna but oh but the cool
thing we got
so well first i want to thank you
because you didn't let me get carnage
out of fries because i was just [ __ ]
up and i wanted to get him but what you
did get me like you were
usually like we'd have we'd stop
somewhere in the middle on the way to
san diego for food
but you're like i'm gonna take care of
you and we went to dairy queen and i got
the best shake
because i had a full well not a full but
like three quarters of a decade why are
you lying to these [ __ ] people you
know you gave me at least three quarters
do you ever stop but you stopped over at
the burrito place by uh the uh
la jolla comedy store still once in a
while don't you like don quixote he sent
over burritos last night no burritos
oh my god it's the greatest
i love the carne asada ones all right
let me show you
i like the other one i had not the
quantities
the chili brain yeah
that's insane i'm still uh i'm still
going that boulevard i'm still at the
bottom of garnett boulevard they have
the taco place next to denny's
that's still one of my all-time [ __ ]
favorite places of all all mexican food
it's cheap you get on the line
i used to get the carnitas with two two
or three tortillas with rice and beans
oh my [ __ ] god what kind of beans do
you like
refried yeah a little bit of cheese on
top a little cheese a couple green
onions whatever they put on there what's
your favorite la local place
mexican
i'm a big fan of el coyote
what's up coyote that's something
no it's too far
is it like a fancy place like there's
like casa vega and sherman oaks
i don't get it i like the little [ __ ]
taco shack that's awesome
i like bumping into weird taco shacks
i've given up on a lot of [ __ ] man i
really have i just stopped we got food
poisoning from her from that one in
north hollywood who did you did but the
one taco stand i got food poisoning
really yeah i [ __ ] blood
bro oh no it was like a 24-hour bug i
got from maybe it was like a bad piece
of meat i had eaten that 30 times and
nice people i watched the
operation sometimes it could just be a
little peek you know
years ago i remember going somewhere you
know who's notorious for giving you
[ __ ] up uh tuna subway
yeah subway be careful with that [ __ ]
tuna it's the worst thing calorie-wise
there i would never get it really
because they put eight pounds of mayo on
it that's why i make tuna at home you
can't get it yeah i like to do it at the
house with some onions and [ __ ] some
mayonnaise some pickled relish nice i
put crushed pepper that's what i did
crushed red pepper look at me he's a
[ __ ] regular
then he puts beans on it and wraps it up
in a turkey and he wraps everything in
the [ __ ]
he can't live with that oh my god those
caesar salad wraps oh jesus what was
wrong with that oh jesus it's [ __ ]
delicious then he eats a bag of french
fries that comes with why eat the
[ __ ] wrap if you're gonna eat the
fries that come with it i'm not eating
you don't eat caesar salad to be healthy
it just sounds like the worst salad you
can get it is i just ate it because it
was delicious and then she said you want
fries and that was hot you like caesar
salad who doesn't
caesar salad it's [ __ ] delicious the
hotel in houston the old hotel the
laptop would put you in
they had a caesar salad the best
spicy anchovy spicy that you said do you
have full anchovies on it they
haven't never done that oh yeah they
slice them thin so you really don't
taste them real thin
and she would tremendous you know we
don't [ __ ] around man i wouldn't sing it
to a but if i forget the name of the
[ __ ] place i ain't gonna you know but
it was cool because i really wanted
those carne saddle fries and like you
just sat me down like no don't get you
don't eat those and that's what i need
the [ __ ] morning i get monkeys dude
my brain goes one in the morning you
already had the [ __ ] rap and you
already had french fries the party's
over right you had the m ms you had the
[ __ ] chips yeah you had the the
[ __ ]
dairy queen you had the
the the what else we are the the taco
you had the thing that the fattest thing
on the mexican menu oh the flowers the
flowers yeah you didn't want the ceviche
with the avocado you know you want the
[ __ ] planters i don't know this you
got ceviche at a place you've never been
before that's scary to me well it's
right there out in the open everybody's
got ceviche out there like ten of the
[ __ ] restaurants have ceviche out
there i bet it was competitive i had
something to lose i don't want to
[ __ ] eat a full mexican meal i don't
want no rice and beans i'm trying to
lose weight so you go with the [ __ ]
ceviche it's tomatoes the jalapenos
you'll gain what an ounce
you're pissed like eight [ __ ] times
ceviche is not bad for you i know the
chips and that's why i got it sure the
chips are bad the chips were 420 [ __ ]
calories for like [ __ ] ten of them
yeah the chips are the worst that was
one thing shocking going to weight
watchers was how bad the chips were i
never how bad mexican food mexican food
in general that's like the worst that's
why that's the last category they have
they're like in the caribbean they mix
it and they have mexican food and
they're like my skull
with [ __ ] crossbones and the fat dude
laying there with his heart blown up
yeah you should always consider eating
mexican as like pizza night in the same
kind of category where it's it's
actually you know pizza nights like a
kind of like a dessert like you know we
worked hard all week let's have get a
pizza friday you know and uh
you don't think of that as mexican you
just think if it's like food but that's
like way worse than having a pizza and
you consider pizza like a special event
when i go to mexico in restaurants i
lose my mind i don't know about any of
you guys there's no control
there's no control you only control i
drink water
but i inhale the [ __ ] salsa i inhaled
the pico de gallo i inhaled the [ __ ]
avocado i inhaled the chips and sauce
that first come with a table because
you're stoned to the gills then the dish
comes
and then you know sour cream
well the [ __ ] up part is the tortillas
if you can kind of cut out the tortillas
and a tortilla is bad for you they're
like 180 each but if you have six tacos
that's a [ __ ] that's like six 700
extra calories like that's that's when i
started putting on the weight before i
started losing again when i started
dating paula a couple years ago you need
to break up with this girl man start
dating an asian chick yeah
mexican food [ __ ] [ __ ] just packs
them on man her mom has been cool her
mom like now like uh measures the food
and it only gives a certain amount she's
cool about it one bucket
oh i know okay yeah mexicans don't have
no [ __ ] servant no she hates it
she tells [ __ ] she tells paula to
stop being mean to me and letting me eat
because she doesn't think that i want to
do all this dieting thing every time she
tries to give me extra food she's funny
sure she looks you got that little
[ __ ] face with those beady eyes
i don't normally have these beady eyes i
couldn't believe he looked at me and
he's like
all right man good night i'm going this
way where you going because i'm going to
get caught in a santa fries
i go where you just walking into the
abyss it's downtown san diego i'm
looking for carne asada fries i'm more
scared of bad carne asada than when i am
[ __ ] shrimp
do you know what i'm saying to you i
know that's one thing i really am scared
of is pork i don't [ __ ] know carney
said his beef
same [ __ ] difference okay okay the
thing that got me [ __ ] sick was
garlic and soda oh okay that's what got
me first i would think shrimp would be
worse than beef i think well you're in
san diego it's not like you're in tempe
arizona where the shrimp is wet right
where they have to fly in [ __ ] nine
hours
you know that's what scares me
but you know to each his own i just
didn't want you to pack on no but i
needed it and like it's like that's what
i've been trying to get better at like
i'll go home and i'll give myself one
thing usually sometimes if i haven't had
dinner yet
but i need that like i need just someone
to say you don't need it and i said no i
don't
no no you go back to your room listen
man every time i'm hungry i go back to
the room and i make coffee
i make coffee and i smoke dope oh my god
and you pass the [ __ ] out old school
right red man
old school on the road eight of us in
the hotel room that one in san francisco
looked like a ship and we go downstairs
and had the red pepper that's right the
clam chowder pepper clam chowder
downstairs who you [ __ ] thinking
these novices don't know dick about dick
that remember that one photo where we're
both sitting in the windowsill together
uh and we're
there's a photo it's me and you we're
both like crammed into this like
windowsill and i remember we were
staring across the street there was all
these police because they found a
chopped up woman's body and a suitcase
floating in the ocean across the street
from the hotel that's right
yeah and so there's this famous picture
this old picture that i have i'll send
it to you that we were just both sitting
there and it's pretty funny that's a
good hotel i'm going to be in san
francisco next month i'm going back to
do the punch line and then sacramento
with tony inch club that's a fun [ __ ]
week there yeah
i like the sushi place in sacramento
right across from the club it's open
till midnight yeah they got a nice
little lunch there they don't [ __ ]
around over there they're gonna give you
a nice salad a little teriyaki's chicken
that doesn't kill you you don't eat the
rice you get the brown rice not too
[ __ ] bad
what's up dog what are you looking for
just hit me like it literally i just
cause you you're evil
you take the chiba cheese and you
squeeze them to make it look like
they're smaller no i don't this is
[ __ ] i'm [ __ ] up
yeah but you ate the other thing nothing
i like that watch that's a very nice
watch thanks man g-shock
uh are you gonna get the apple watch
i don't even know what the [ __ ] apple
watches my dad wants it but it's like a
thousand dollars or 600 bucks it starts
off at like 300 but yeah it goes up to
actually 10 thousand dollars
idiots so you will see all like the
people trying to impress us with our
their ten thousand dollar version of the
watch but
uh i i missed the pre-order i totally
just wasn't thinking about it and then
so now it's like
it doesn't ship till june or something
so i'm like huh but you're not gonna get
it do you want it i don't understand
you're gonna make a call from your watch
no no no it's more i think it's more
like you can keep your phone in your
pocket somebody texts you you can just
look at and go yes
uh or you know like or if like you get
an alert like an email you'd be like
okay he said 15 minutes you know instead
of having to take out my phone unlock my
phone like go in like it's more i think
it's going to be just for quick things
you know like or like if you're driving
if you're driving and like you have gps
and you're like i think i have to turn
yep turn right here
and you know it might it might be good
for little things i think this is great
because look
fonts unlocked two seconds i just
i and then i use this as my gps i don't
see any need so instead of just like
unlocking your phone where you're
driving and how about doing this
but you don't even need to your phone's
up here on the dashboard or at least for
me it is i don't know
you know that's illegal that's a lot of
money
that's a lot of money for a watch oh i
agree i agree um everything apple does
there's a lot of [ __ ] money it's
gonna break in two years
that's the the thing you know they don't
make these iphones the last 10 years
guys
they tell those little chinese guys
before they jump off the [ __ ]
building listen make these things so
they bring them back in 18 months then
we'll give them a refurbished one until
they buy the [ __ ] six or the seven or
the 8g or the nine sport apple don't
[ __ ] around itunes don't [ __ ] around
itunes [ __ ] around with you itunes
don't play
at all at all there's no [ __ ]
nonsense with apple so people know when
apple shows up you're going deep into
the [ __ ] pockets of debt that's true
and that's what they do you know why
would you let let's be all be honest
here everybody in this room i'm a
[ __ ] computer [ __ ] but you're a
computer illiterate and you're whatever
literate whatever the [ __ ] both he is
but let's just get back to basics here
would you buy the first model or
something for ten thousand dollars what
if you bring it home and that watch goes
[ __ ] bananas so let's take sending
you pictures of your wife naked and
[ __ ] beeping at you every 10 minutes
they don't know right like google glass
just failed and i don't even know why
yeah all these you know at the beginning
they can't they don't have all these
glitches man so you're paying 10 000
[ __ ] dollars for watches that are
gonna last [ __ ] two years and every
two years they're gonna sap you every
two years they have they don't they're
not [ __ ] billionaires because they're
not making money over there they're
making this [ __ ] and [ __ ] hong kong
they're getting three dollars a [ __ ]
hour they're jumping off the [ __ ]
building like it's going out of style
and my line they do a 60-minute [ __ ]
report and they sell it they sell this
[ __ ] ten thousand a watch who needs a
watch for ten thousand [ __ ] uh
whatever just looking up at the [ __ ]
wall
what if i'm just looking up at the wall
i just saying [ __ ] two dollars
i just saved two dollars two dollars i
just saved eight [ __ ] dollars how's
that
a ten thousand dollar watch what's it
gonna do gonna give you a compass it's
gonna do the iphone in the [ __ ] in
your watch right that's it but you still
gotta have the iphone they're gonna get
you with the watts they're gonna charge
it you have to charge it every morning
listen guys you know what i keep it
[ __ ] simple i don't even have a watch
i got two watches at the house one works
and one doesn't ask me what brand they
are some french i have no [ __ ] ideas
watch do i care i you know you look up
where isn't there a clock today
and you have your i like the phone thing
i get when you're driving that i guess
it'd be cool but i always people are
always walking around you said the magic
[ __ ] word what cool
this is all about cool guys that's true
starbucks is all about cool
you know it used to be that when you
walk in a bar and you see somebody they
come up to you like this don't they with
their bottle up here
nobody has it over here nobody has
enough nobody just leaves at the [ __ ]
table because they might get roofied at
captain jack's [ __ ] titty joint what
the [ __ ] were you doing there anyway
i love that place
why don't why don't you like that place
it's not a real strip club it's just a
burlesque bar it's changing my [ __ ]
points my point
my point i want to go see his chick with
nipple rings i'm a grown [ __ ] man
either show me that swamp or [ __ ]
pull it away
i don't hear him saying you're going to
show up with a curtain in front of your
[ __ ]
i don't want to see i don't i'm too old
i don't want to see [ __ ] art for you
people who are saying joey but [ __ ] you
i'm a grown [ __ ] man chilly i don't
want to see nipple rings i want you to
jump out here and show me those [ __ ]
when we did the comedy show at the
improv it was a [ __ ] bullet show
right either sit there with the chick
with uh like a liner and her [ __ ]
i don't need to see
show me your [ __ ] so it was kind of
disappointing yeah it was cool to watch
for a minute but then get the [ __ ] out
of here the whole time i was looking for
a knife
to do what to stab myself and then you
like a mass [ __ ] suicide i like bruce
jenner
there was a there was a good uh police
chase today did you see that it's so
crazy you're obsessed with those it's
every single day it's like oh hey it's
here's a real version of cops you know i
love that show cops
now we get a four-hour version that's
live and you never you know today was a
death suicide by cop and uh oh did he do
it i don't know because they
they the helicopter was told to leave
because it was just getting too intense
like swat teams and
cops
no no this guy was in his car with like
i guess a shotgun and he was on the
phone and just smoking cigarettes and
they had like had him surrounded and i
guess he was saying that he uh he was
trying to do death by cop you know where
he like comes out or they shoot him and
you know suicide by cop but uh they they
did they flew away and that they were
told to leave so i don't know what
happened i mean shoot
and yeah shoot him right in the [ __ ]
yeah did he ever run from the cops joey
run from the cops had a real smile
but not like that not like with a
helicopter and a bank robbery
i ran from cops a bunch of really yeah
like they would chase you on foot oh my
god both
cars and foot
did you think you're going to get away
i got away a couple times oh [ __ ]
yeah that was before helicopters
no but it was definitely before
as you know nowadays it's like infrared
helicopters they can see you at night
yeah if the helicopter's on you pretty
much just give up right that you're
[ __ ] dead because even after they
look for you
they go to other things to find where
the [ __ ] you went like after you get
home that's when they find you an hour
later when they go back to the ironing
board
and look at all the computers in the
area and see
you just dipping and dashing
do i got chased by cops a [ __ ] couple
of times
one of the best ones ever was when i got
into a fight with carol in seattle on
the cops came
and i jumped into the ocean
and they could not find me what and they
went to the edge with the flashlight and
everything and i was right under
wow were you under the water
under the water but like looking up at
them
but i was so close to the thing the ways
it was [ __ ] freezing i thought it was
like three feet of [ __ ] water
i thought i was gonna go in and it was
low tide so the water was gonna go up to
my [ __ ] knees [ __ ] you i went
straight down
wow and i thought i was just gonna duck
in the water
and they were just gonna look around and
go you know it's high tide whatever
we're not even gonna these [ __ ]
walked all the way to the edge
and i'm down there like
but you couldn't hear me kicking because
the waves were hitting this uh wall it
was down by alki
aokai right on seattle beats that sort
the [ __ ] penguins it's
that water is freezing that's alaska
water that was one time
another time with her in the car we got
into a fight she ripped up my check and
i pulled the hair
and the cops chased me and i hid inside
a dumpster oh yeah for [ __ ] nine
hours eight hours i jump out of the
dumpster i walk half the block and
they're waiting for me in the bushes
they knew i was in the [ __ ] dumpster
i have never even had a speeding ticket
before
come on
the best chase i got involved in though
was when i robbed the bookie and it went
down
that went from
57th
and park avenue in western new york new
jersey
and it went to 69th 70th street and
kennedy boulevard in north bergen but
you're going joey it's 59th to 70th it's
11 blocks
it's 11 blocks this way but it was like
10 blocks this way you're following me
from where that happened was right by
the hudson river and i had to get all
the way across town by sea caucus
guys you have no idea and they were on
they were going up and down blocks are
you on foot
foot [ __ ] what do you think i
had a bicycle with a helmet no foot
oh my god and my hand was ripped
this [ __ ] guy so
uh
as i'm getting to my house i mean i'm
maybe 50 yards from my front door
i see the door
and something makes me look up and it's
a cop car coming down my block without
its lights on
no lights no red lights no headlights no
nothing so i couldn't catch it
he didn't see me we just missed each
other as soon as i saw him i ducked
under a car and as he got like 10 feet
from he started flashing his light out
i crossed the street and that was it i
went downstairs i took the glove no i
left the glove on i changed my clothes
and about an hour later they picked me
up and i went to the bar that was one of
the worst jesus chases ever the [ __ ]
cops like two of them were on foot and i
lost them and the other ones weren't
cars is your heart just racing the
entire time oh my god it was tremendous
[ __ ]
it's tremendous
so uh in cops and stuff they actually
think they're going to get away like
like it just seems so stupid watching
cops and they show you the episodes
where they [ __ ] catch it yeah there's
20 [ __ ] shots where they look for you
and you you know
listen man when it's dark and [ __ ] like
that you get you could move but you got
to move
yeah you got to [ __ ] move and catch a
break and catch a corner it's got to
happen quick because they usually come
by themselves or maybe with one but in
four minutes you'll have three more cars
there once they say it's a foot pursuit
and in 10 minutes you'll have four more
[ __ ] cars there so it's all by the
minute and quickness boom boom boom this
way but you know i'm talking about if
you [ __ ] get into a fist fight
if you rob a [ __ ] a coke dealer and
they're chasing like the coke dealer got
hurt you shot them in the leg or
something they're not gonna pull out no
[ __ ] helicopters by the time the
helicopter shoots over you're hidden
you know unless you fall or they pick up
like a t-shirt and they get like a dog
out there or something but
then again
i don't know
i don't know the extent of it really
i was watching netflix has this cool
show
it's like serial killers would like talk
about their crimes and it was this dude
in new york
who just went and like started stabbing
people and he would hide it was like 36
hours
that he just killed like her girlfriend
the girlfriend's mom and this other dude
nice guy
oh my god and then he was talking about
like hiding in new york for the night
and i just i can't it's like i always
laugh in grand theft auto when if you
wait 30 seconds the cops just give up
but
it's just crazy how like how could you
imagine having someone chasing after you
36 hours can you imagine if grand theft
auto lee lasted like they those cops
went home to investigate you and then
like so you have all these like like
murder cases uh playing grand theft auto
see like 2 000 people after you
i like investigating you have to think
like they do
the cops don't work like they do on csi
[ __ ] miami the general public thinks
that they drop a hair
they're going to send it and they're
going to get their hair resolved back in
two [ __ ] days and you're going to get
guys there's so much [ __ ] bureaucracy
that [ __ ] costs money
so before they send your hair and like i
remember one time i lived under this guy
in colorado and he would come over to
eat every night
his name was ken but he was from
kentucky so he just called kentucky and
he'd come every night and eat on we'd
always show up when food dinner was
serving he goes
what is it that i smell is that lobster
tails maybe i can get a piece and you
know we're family well you know if i get
a piece we give a piece of one of our
and one day he comes home this
[ __ ] goes my mama just sent me
200 hours i'm gonna have a good weekend
i'm like dog buy a bag of wheat come on
down here he's like oh no my momma sent
me this is for me and my brother's like
[ __ ] him in the back of my mouth i'm
like this is [ __ ] mine
that money is mine i'm gonna rob that
[ __ ] he lived right on top of me
he went out that night and i knew he was
a cheap buck he wasn't gonna take the
200 cash
so one way or another i creeped into his
apartment i took like the 200. the one
way or another and then i put tables
together and i creeped up through his
balcony
i put like a bar a table on top of a
barbecue
on top of something else and i climbed
up and grabbed myself up up the [ __ ]
balcony and put my leg over and he left
the screen door open which really
shocked me and i went into his house i
searched i could not find the [ __ ]
money anyway
i left the front door open when i went
downstairs inside thinking about it
where am i when i put the money i went
back upstairs in the pharmacy like in
this kitchen in his bed bathroom there
was a thing of band-aids i opened it up
and there was the two that just [ __ ]
cashed the next one this jerk off comes
down he's like man
somebody robbed my house last night i
knew it was one of you new jersey
criminals
right me and my my buddies howling
because my buddy knows it's me he's like
going
and we're like
i'm like with the straight face come on
who robbie we're gonna find out i just
went and got scott's tape and got
fingerprints off the glass and nothing
he goes i just sent it to the fbi
[ __ ] you i didn't miss a beat i knew he
had dick you know i'm saying like i
don't give a [ __ ] by the time you get
into the fall off i'll beat that in
court with a [ __ ] with lee i'll put a
yarmulke in a black suit
and take him to court and say
authenticity some big [ __ ] words and
they'll fold
it really probably
it really would work because they just
at one point they're telling you they
got fingerprints they have to show them
to you they have to show you the points
and prove it to you as an attorney
they're going to try to cut a deal right
off the bat you're going to go why are
they kind of deal so suspiciously that's
why because they have partial
fingerprints show me the [ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah
keep the dick
it's like when i got uh in trouble when
i was underage drinking at a bar and the
cops came in and i was holding a drink
and i threw it in the trash can they'd
put me in that paddy wagon and had to go
to court and i had you know i was 18 and
i had a public defender and he's just
like did they take the drink out of the
trash can i'm like no and he goes all
right say you weren't drinking and he's
like i'm like what he goes they need to
have evidence to you know you know to
book you on anything i'm like are you
sure and he goes yeah so went to court
cops like no i don't have that evidence
obviously you know i didn't get trash
can they're like well case dismissed
that's it there's so many [ __ ]
loopholes right that they have to do
one time i was living in snowman's
village and i had this idea that i was
going to rob the jewelry store
and take the jewelry and sell in new
york for the holidays and walk out there
like 50 grand
it was a mom-and-pop jewelry store i
went to this [ __ ] dude who until this
day
today now that i think about it and you
guys know i process everything today i
think this guy was an undercover agent
because he was an electrician
and he knew alarm systems like he told
me you know alarm systems and [ __ ] but
ever since i started telling them my
luck started changing
and i went to this place and it was like
they knew i was coming
i cut the wire and also and they [ __ ]
up because they came up there with their
lights on
this is one time where these idiots kept
their life which gave me they're three
miles away i'm in the colorado mountains
i see the lights coming up this is easy
so i stop what i'm doing i jump the
fence and i run straight home i lived in
the valley i just run through the snow
snow's coming down
i run home i [ __ ] kick my breath
i don't listen about an hour later guys
there's a knock on the [ __ ] door it's
like four cops like how you doing
great night great [ __ ] up weather like
listen we had a robbery in the name the
guy ran all the way here
what a coincidence and we're like no
did anybody come here tonight we're like
no it was just me and my roommate
like can we come inside big mistake they
came in and they go
so you didn't go out there i'm like no
they looked into my boots i left them
there and there was snow melting on them
and they're like well whoever boots
there oh they were out they had me but
they couldn't arrest me they had no
[ __ ] proof there was no
uh tools out left in the open nothing
like that that's another time i got
chasey like jesus
it's like it's in my life now because
like paula's gonna be a little
prosecutor
and then in boston there's two important
cases going on like there's aaron
hernandez and then that bomber dude
and it's just
it's kind of [ __ ] up when you think
about like the jury
how like they they get to decide on
people's lives
like they just be on like you have to
just guess
it's like there's no real like you don't
know if it's real and i think that guy
bombed the the marathon
but they were why even have a trial like
what what are they gonna there's no way
they're gonna find them not guilty
it just seems like a waste
well i think with the bomber they were
gonna they try them to
see if they're gonna give them the death
penalty correct that's what they're
going that's what they're designing i
think they're going on there whether
they're going to kill this [ __ ] poor
mormon or not
and then hernandez might get off now
they're saying i don't i don't know i
didn't follow it that much i don't know
what the [ __ ] going on it's like that
[ __ ] you have to listen we live in the
united states you have a due process
here that's why they do that [ __ ] they
spend millions on those [ __ ] court
cases right millions and even if he gets
[ __ ] convicted then he goes on death
row and that's 22 million other repeals
you're not going to [ __ ] zap him till
he's [ __ ] 50.
so
what are you going to do it's just a
part of [ __ ] growing up right it's
too high-profile cases they got to run
it you know so what those you saw those
jurors they never heard what was going
on with this football player they never
[ __ ] he was hurting the new england
patriots because that's basically you
got to go in there right those aaron
hernandez guys have to go in there
saying we don't even know who the
england patriots are
we don't know anything about this case
tell me guys you guys don't know what
shit's going on because it doesn't
appeal to you but you've heard of it
right so even if you've heard of the
situation
you're [ __ ] biased right that's what
i think all the time
so did you have a judge or a jury i had
a judge [ __ ] that i don't take it to
jerusalem okay i was guilty
i ain't [ __ ] around cut me a deal
[ __ ] i'll say that thousands you
understand me
no if you gotta if you're pleading the
case or you're a high-profile case a
high-profile matter
listen the beautiful thing about the law
is that you have a proof behind a
reasonable doubt
that's all it takes to be guilty but
that's all it takes to be not guilty
a reasonable doubt
so me as an attorney i'm going to take
my [ __ ] out i'm gonna go in there with
lee i'm gonna tell you lee you're
looking at 60 years you're gonna die
anyway so what do you give a [ __ ] let me
work these [ __ ] a little bit
let's work this cop let's work this
evidence
there was a lieutenant who's a little
weak the breach of command a good
attorney see little things
so they attack the [ __ ] trial
and you know what what a great thing to
prove somebody wrong
by look at the oj thing that's the one
that stands in my mind everybody knew
this [ __ ] played football
everybody watches tv they saw him
running through a [ __ ] airport in a
commercial correct
right when they go to their bias right
off the bat he was married to a white
woman there was so many [ __ ] uh
mitigate little [ __ ] things but his
attorneys attacked the dna the knife
they attacked the fingerprints that were
never really processed on the gate that
they had oj that they never really
processed because it rained and it
washed some of that [ __ ] blood off a
lot of people don't know that there was
so many little [ __ ] things in the oj
trial
that you know but think about that he
paid the money he got four powerhouse
attorneys to go in and break down one
guy first of all if your wife goes to
work for a big attorney firm right like
a big attorney firm they eat up the
district attorney's office dude was that
an earthquake i'm sorry i think i i was
freaking out because i don't [ __ ]
know because i looked over at you and i
thought you were hitting the table just
like
what the [ __ ] i thought it was too i was
about just from manpower it's like it's
like when you go up against a high it's
like if l.a county it's like if i
murdered somebody tonight and i go out
there and get an attorney that right off
the bat i gotta give him a check for 250
000. that's my first check though like
they won't even talk to me
250 000 we need another office by three
o'clock on the wire and that's how it
starts
that's how the clock starts with those
[ __ ]
they're gonna take it to trial and
they're gonna try to
but that's the beauty about working
living in the united states i gotta ask
you something red man before you you
know rush no i i just i'm just making
sure i'm okay just stop with the [ __ ]
pulse everybody's gonna live here we'll
pop domino's pizza we'll get you some
wings of blue cheese everybody'll be
[ __ ] happy you eat domino's wings no
i'm just saying for you guys because i
know it'll make your heart go pedal
paddle if you see a domino wing leak it
would if you saw a domino wing two of
them you'd probably come all over
yourself you're like domino wings man
they're michael they're not great he
loves dominoes he loves little caesars i
don't love little caesars but it's not
bad for five dollars he loves it
he's jewish little caesars he'll buy a
pie keep the other one for the next day
oh olive garden has a new meal where you
can get you know unlimited salad and
bread sticks and then you order a dish
and then you get a dish to take home of
a different dish so you can have it the
next morning so what you do is you go
there you eat all the salt and bread
sticks you can tell you can't eat
anymore get the alfredo dipping sauce
take both of them home now you have two
meals for 12.99 wait what what do you
dip the alfredo in the breadsticks in
the alfredo oh no it's two dollars oh
jesus christ that's that's the sound
i've never done that yeah and that's
true it's not bad and the soup is
[ __ ] not bad either
if you have like on the east coast do
you dip the bread sticks and
fettuccine sauce though oh oh you got to
see me it's all over my [ __ ] face
i wouldn't eat that fettuccine [ __ ]
yeast infection juice if you paid me
every time i say fettuccine alfredo yeah
alfredo i think of a yeast infection
that's what that sauce looks like it's
good though it's disgusting
alfredo it's good pasta i've never had a
bread it's italian
dude that was an earthquake how do you
know uh everyone's tweeting like crazy
about it
that's a good one who gives a [ __ ] ah
i'm so glad it is an earthquake because
i was like my god i'm having a heart
attack i need to call the ambulance
i thought you were like doing this this
is the second time the church has been
going live and we've been struck by a
[ __ ] earthquake and we survived it so
take that to the bank for you people at
home [ __ ] doing jumping jacks what do
you think of the state of podcasting
right now lee had some interesting
questions this weekend
um it's interesting i uh
i personally
am over it
a little uh because i'm just uh
you know when i when we started death
squad i've always done it as a video
podcast you guys have done it as a video
podcast but i focused it on a video i
called it desktop.tv
and i had all the shows under one name
on itunes and everything like that
because what i have always thought is
that
once uh apple catches up and like these
you know roku boxes and stuff like that
catches up we're all just going to be
a network we're not we're going to be
right next to nbc it's going to be nbc
joey diaz channel joe rogan channel you
know and it's and so my idea was always
to have like a one channel and then have
all these shows like tv shows after it
now i think what podcasting did was uh
start off that trend uh that idea
everyone started a podcast of the the
the amount that got through and are
still doing it today i have now a lot of
them have switched to video podcasts
also or they have a camera on and stuff
like that um
but i also see that i think podcasting
and audio i it just feels like i'm not
hearing about it as much as i was two
years ago two years ago it was like
podcast podcast do a podcast podcast
pack where now it's more like uh
uh i'm doing a twitch i'm doing a video
game show now or i'm doing a show about
this and or we're doing a live show like
you know
uh a live show where we film while we're
on the road and i don't know man it's
very interesting right now and
especially for me because i i i
personally you know once you've said so
many things i mean podcasts are long and
you know once you've done a couple of
hundreds and hundreds of them it really
gets to a point where it's it's kind of
you can't dip into all the fun stuff
that you used to dip into anymore like
oh i haven't talked to him about the
girl that you know i murdered and i
haven't talked to about you know this
and that and that and stuff you can't
really do that anymore because you've
already done that so it's kind of like
i think you get to a point where you're
just like okay uh
i need to i need to start tripping when
robbing banks more now or i gotta i felt
i had to just start going on the off the
deep end a little just to get uh
not stale and uh to to keep it exciting
and fresh and
i don't know it's interesting it's it's
uh
i have been doing less of them and uh
i'm more happier uh i was doing way too
many
uh you know i was doing all the joe
rogan ones and now i'm only doing like
half the joe rogan ones uh i've been i
was doing like four five six different
podcasts a week
now i'm doing two
uh
and
it's it's just
i think for me i was just spreading it
too thin uh and i kind of got
bored with it a little
um but now
uh since i've cut back the ones i do i
have fun on them again so i discussed
this this weekend how
you know people are great to have great
podcasts you know
but uh
i get a hit up five times a week to do a
different podcast it's not to have
something against
uh other people's podcasts it's that i
have one myself and i gotta be fresh out
here twice they've already heard the
[ __ ] stories
they've already heard my logic you know
so now
i'm gonna go do two more podcasts which
they're gonna ask me the same questions
over again how i ended up in prison how
i ended up a coming
so i just said i can't because i just
have enough time for two a week i love
doing joe's you know i go up to joe's or
lose my mind for an hour that's a great
but besides that it's somewhere i gotta
drive to it's not like well you have to
call my skype at 2 45. i don't know what
the [ __ ] i'm gonna be doing at 2 45 i'm
not going to audition i [ __ ] won you
don't live here it's tough to really
connect with you i'm gonna have to go
home and get the email and email you
forget it so i feel the same way you
have i started burning out for a while
and that's why i just do two a week just
to keep me fresh sometimes i'll do them
on sundays sometimes i do them in the
mornings sometimes i'll do them monday
nights tomorrow and i have something so
i figured i'd do it tonight that's the
reason [ __ ] why also yeah i love
switching the format around i love it i
can't do nothing the same way [ __ ]
twice right i'm sorry i i don't mind
switching up not having a guest and just
coming out here stone
to the gills and that's the great thing
i always thought about the podcast
though
that i knew that i would do well with
because
i wanted to let people know where my
heart was
that's it that was the most important
thing that whatever they
judged up on stage or whatever the [ __ ]
i was talking about on stage that
instead of leaving that a little
negative on the negative side it's like
you know what maybe he's having a bad
night i listen to him on the podcast and
i know where his heart is at
well i did the longest yard i felt that
in atlanta that time
i felt in a lot of cities that people
just really didn't [ __ ] like me man
but you know for something stupid that
came out of my mouth that i thought was
funny at the time
and i think that's the that's the
advantage we have over richard pryor and
bill hicks that we have a chance to go
home and do a second chance this is a
second chance come on here and talk
about what we like what we don't like
what we like to eat what we don't like
to [ __ ] eat if i don't like to walk
all over [ __ ] san diego to get a
shrimp taco it just gives you your
perspective i always wanted them to know
what was in my heart and what was in my
soul you know and that's that's what i
want with this podcast at this point
that's it
people always hit you up with ideas what
you should do what you shouldn't do you
know lee and i have discussed it i know
what i want to do and i know what works
for me i i couldn't do four of these a
week
i can't do this i can't do three of
these a week it's it's spring it's the
law diminishing return something's gonna
suffer
for a while that i was on the road every
week for like 12 weeks the podcast
started to suffer it was too much it was
just too much it was too much leaving on
thursday i got to do it in two days
sometimes it's great doing a podcast i'm
not doing one for three days then doing
it again that's the whole you know yeah
i mean when i started really going at it
you know when me and joe started the joe
rogan thing and then
right after that started doing the death
squad stuff
you know that's been about four years or
so
when i when death squads first started i
mean i was literally working all day
long
doing joe's stuff then doing death squad
stuff and at night editing not only had
that
taken so much i mean i i for the first
time in my life i feel like oh my god i
can just lay on the couch if i want to
and watch the tv i haven't been able to
do this in four years
uh
just all that
that work and all that that stress and
being able to just stop for a second i
think it's so important because i i i
mean i've never had
a part of my life for for four years i
didn't have a real day off of work you
know like i mean you
most jobs you did like i'll take two
weeks off i might go to you know florida
or something like that i i really
haven't done that you know like i i've
gone home uh to visit my mom for a few
days or but i also had a comedy show and
i was also you know i was the one
booking that and having to get the the
rental car and like it's like i've been
doing so much work that it's like i i
feel like the president when he goes in
the term where he gets gray hair for
four years or eight years like i feel
like that has happened to me and that
was the roughest four years i've just
gotten through with and now i'm just
like i'm i'm almost beat up like i feel
like it don't work yeah now what are you
gonna do before we go retire no no no i
gotta now it starts all over again it's
like you're getting a second wind you
write some jokes you stay home for a few
months you regroup you stay like you
said you're only not drinking three
nights a week now you're only drinking
four nights four nights a week so just
three nights that you don't drink
and you refuel and you go back out there
and you start making a living you put
some money away and then it just it
speaks in valleys man look at don
marrero
diamond robert you look at dom he's on
every [ __ ] week i'm lazy compared to
none
you know but i also have the wife and
the child
which takes a lot of my [ __ ] time
like what's up
we made it back from san diego to the
valley last night an hour 40. don't you
love that i've done that once before
awesome i used to do hollywood and then
howard 20 when i used to work in la
jolla the black drug dealer had we
closed at one so i had to beat the clock
and i'd do it last night we did
190 percent of the way
the happiest i've ever seen you was when
we reached irvine in under an hour you
just got this big smile on your face and
you was like you were like it's exciting
you were doing a hundred
and then and then you were playing oh
yeah come over as we were coming up
immigration [ __ ] bananas when i heard
that
i was cutting people off to get the
immigration that was the line we had a p
and i had a stop of immigration
immigration held us for like seven
minutes if not we would have we had we
had a great time we made great time
coming from san diego san diego is a
great
[ __ ]
city and i get it you know what man you
look at those women what they have on
the food the clothes out
in front it's only open till two right
it's it's no [ __ ] little white it's a
little white in the little one military
but that's good because you kind of feel
a little bit more protected
you know you go to vegas and you see
these people
i mean let's face it vegas is 50 los
angeles people around the weekend that's
why sunset's [ __ ] dead on friday and
saturday there's nobody on sunset
but you go to san diego and they have
their own little las vegas down there
they're [ __ ] that gaslamp there was
thousands of people out there thousands
leave both [ __ ] night thousands
traffic people on bicycles
pushing people around it's like oh my
god one recognized me and gave me a ride
when i had to go get you some medicine
yeah i got i ran outside of the club
and this dude was like are you leave
from the podcast and he he took me on
that little pedal bike thing to cvs nice
yeah one thing i don't like about it is
that just not as friendly with marijuana
for sure like like i mean i've smoked
weed like in an alley outside you know
in the gas lamp and i've had people like
abraham tell me about hey you shouldn't
be doing that here and get that out of
here and like it's not it's not like la
where you just walk down the sidewalks
start smoking weed
they that's why they don't have
dispensaries there or they didn't for a
while they only have delivery services
there they don't like marijuana in san
diego as much as la that's one big part
that that technology i smoked i smoked
something i spoke at the club downstairs
yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah look at you but right but how many
because i had to figure it out for my
taxes
how many free podcasts have you done
like
joey's always paid me he's always been
always he always give me something for i
did
almost 200 free what the [ __ ]
uh someone got beat up but i did almost
200 free podcasts last year
and it's just like
i hear comedians talking a lot about
p uh bookers taking advantage of them
like that like
they won't pay them for the shows
except and i get i get comedians are
also some that they're not not a lot of
money so you don't need to pay producers
uh a lot but like i was talking to vicky
peasant last week
she doesn't get paid it's just
it's so much more it's it's a lot of
work i mean i worked for joe full time
so i i do whatever joe tells me to do he
wants me to edit a video i if i make a
website so i've gotten paid you know
i would have got paid anyways
but for every single other podcast i've
ever done i've never got paid right yeah
and we're talking probably over a
thousand uh
and all these podcasts became a lot of
these podcasts became big and they're
some of the biggest podcasts out you
know like arisha fears you know uh uh
tom segura and christina positzky the
naughty show and i mean the bone zone
with
whatever but uh but i i never did it for
that i did it just to
because these were all my friends just
to help them out because for a while me
and joey and ari and duncan and all
these guys have been on the road and you
know and and nothing you know joey would
get a commercial here duncan would get a
commercial here and these little little
things but uh i you know just knowing
all these people was like there has to
be a way to get people to fall in love
with them and you know what it is it's
repetition it's being able to it's it's
learning who this person is and then
hearing this person again and then
hearing next thing you know
this person just like any kind of radio
dj in the past is now you know who that
person is you want you feel comfortable
hearing this person because you already
know this person's story so it's very
it's very cool to be able to do that for
all these people and all and all my
friends and i never did it for them the
money i just did it because i thought it
was cool that that i could do it you
know like to be able to make a show and
now people are watching that show and
they love everyone that's on the show
and and and that that i mean i i i do
the least leah actually i've never been
paid and it's it's bankrupting me now
i'm bankrupt right now i i have to
write a check tomorrow for 99 of what i
have in my checking account
it sucks
you know it it's it's uh
it's bad right now
and i probably have to get rid of death
squad studio pretty soon too
yeah because it's like it's you know
it's like uh it's the whole thing cost
me with like insurance you know and all
the bills for it for it and and the rent
i'm looking almost about two thousand
dollars
you know so so i have to design and
create and make a t-shirt that will sell
at least two thousand dollars a month so
i can pay for that so it doesn't take
out of my living money and then and then
i you know i had something break the
other day and i had to buy a new
soundboard it was like 500 so i have to
you know it's all that stuff and after a
while it it took any kind of money
bank accounts or anything it just took
it all out and so
i while my hobby got out of control i
need to figure out a way to still be
able to do it still like to do it and
and and make it a little bit more
efficient because right now it's you
know it's it's just it just took
everything i got so that's what i'm
doing with now getting roofied
crazy chicks trying to get revenge
feeling fake earthquakes
i'll be in vancouver by the way next
monday for 4 20. if anyone's listening
we haven't gotten to that yeah
you're doing shout outs i'm going to
give a shout out to my man mikey vincent
scott lim miles dung
talking lamb making a [ __ ] comeback
on twitter
carlos nos guan
paul diese
anthony gravala
petey garcia and paul lynch i love you
[ __ ] did that they understand me
how about you lee
what's up buddy everything all right
we're a little ninja turtle straight up
sidekicks for jesus you wanna do some
tony bennett
sure whatever you want my friend it's
monday what do you wanna have do you
have a question no i got no [ __ ]
questions just put it on will you please
wait
are you [ __ ] kidding me or what
jesus christ
there goes my
my nervous system
nice very soothing
i'm gonna go home and nappy noodles my
highest buck also
had two cheebo juice a rubber thing i
had the whole thing yeah
yes i did it's [ __ ] sunday that's it
i had [ __ ] to do other than that
we got home at 2 30 what time we got
home
140 yeah
i uh
i went and got gas
i went home i emptied the suitcase i
hooked up the sleep apnea machine i took
a shower
it was like maybe 2 20 and i watched
some tv till about 3 30.
i got up at 7 30 the baby was already up
my wife is sick
so i took a shower i made breakfast
and i took the baby to the [ __ ] park
i left the house at like 8 30 though oh
god
i was wiped out i didn't think i was
going to make it today that's how i
always look at life now i'm like oh my
god i'm tired what if i was snorting a
grandma blow last night how bad would i
feel right now
i feel this bad and i didn't do any
blood last night jesus [ __ ] like i
need my sleep now like a three hour
night and sun saturday nights my body's
used to it my body gets [ __ ] on saturday
nights two three hours tops maybe an
hour on the plane
and then i get about two hours about two
or three in the afternoon that sunday i
don't get [ __ ] on sundays for sleep
so my body's used to it i took it down
we walked around we stopped and got some
water
i'm gonna get some ice cream but she
made too much of a [ __ ] mess
and then uh where did we go i don't even
know i mean the wife took her that was
it it was a short date that i went to
jujitsu
i thought i had i mean i met somebody
the other day that used to do jiu jitsu
for you at the first place you did i
forget where it was but uh the comedy
store yeah yeah they came down with me
that's right yeah the girls uh deborah
and uh
nani honey i said steve yeah and they
all go to the new place i go to now
but when this whole phenomenon came
apart
when it came to me
i can't lie to you guys this had nothing
to do with money
this had nothing to do with money i
didn't look at this as money
i looked at this as an opportunity i was
like this is the opportunity i've been
waiting for to tell a story to tell a
[ __ ] story honey to tell my story how
it affected me how it molded me
you know and
that was it
then i started hearing all these [ __ ]
things
people making this people making that
people making this and again it's like
that old thing that after a while
you know me and red band editors and
you're still assisting everything how
bad do you feel
so after a while you have to step in and
no and it's not like i didn't i don't
even know where to pick up sponsors they
start looking you down they start
hitting you up on libsyn and you know
whatever
and then when lee when we you know
when lee came on board i figured
i didn't want any drama so we got to pay
him we got to figure out a way to
[ __ ] pay me so we got to get the
sponsors but this was never really about
money for me
this is always about
getting to let people know who the [ __ ]
you were with this supplemental with
some videos
and that's the [ __ ] up part because it
is so cool like i feel bad asking for
money from people
like i did 200 and it's the [ __ ] up
part is people like oh you're having fun
yeah it's [ __ ] a great it's a great
gig but
at a certain point when you're here
uploading a podcast and and playing with
the levels because it doesn't sound
right to you
and then
lips in the upload fails you're like
[ __ ]
at a certain point doing 200 i only did
200 of them yeah you thousands free yeah
and i'm now now i'm editing 4k video
with two camera angles and i mean i'm
rendering i always see that you do that
i'm like why would you do that to
yourself
for a vimeo video i was like oh jesus
yeah that's a lot of work that's a good
question
i learned something early on i learned
that
and it's not just hollywood it's life
you know people are going to get
whatever you let them take from me
okay people are going to get whatever
you know who lends for if any
60 000
then gives them another 40 000
i told josh wolfe on the phone the idea
that there's people that want to be
victims
there's people that want to walk around
and walk into the comments and go ah
what happened right man how many shall
we d is 10 000.
trump diaz does blow
every night why are we going to well he
told me his cat was sick
are you [ __ ] kidding me he's
somewhere in vegas getting his dick
something right now 10 000. and you're
not going to get it some people want to
be [ __ ] victims you know
uh
i don't even know what my point was
that's how i am yeah i know i
it's just been a weird trippy night
because i can't tell if i keep on
feeling things that are early you're
hearing earthquakes
it's an ambulance type of knife but
it might be he might be calling like
9-1-1 on himself or some [ __ ] the
mexicans looking over the wall some
[ __ ] [ __ ]
but no it's uh you know you do this to
i enjoy it i really do enjoy doing these
i just don't want to do that every day
but what i was talking about was la's a
place where they do this thing okay when
i first came to la i was under the
assumption that when you did a movie you
were a millionaire
like when i before anything about movies
i just thought that whenever you did a
movie you were set for life then i came
out that way and i started hearing what
the rules were
and i could still live with it you know
as being a comic getting 15 a spot at
the comedy store you want to pay me 6.95
a day
to shoot a scene in a movie or a tv
whatever tv was eight whatever it was
i could live with that red man you know
i could live with that legion
but then the union agreed to this new
thing
it's called the sag low budget film and
they have even an ultra low budget
which is 50 a day where's the glamour
where's the glamour
that's what this is all about i'm a
comedy store guy i'm dirty
if you give me a beer that's half drunk
and i'm snorting blow i'll drink it you
know if there's a half a cigarette in
the ashtray outside the comedy store i'm
coked up i'll take it out there and
finish that [ __ ] cigarette i'm a
dirty dude when you go on a movie set
that's why you want to go on a movie set
your room is clean you gotta drink you
know you get taken care of for three or
four days
i came to this town i was very fortunate
my first thing was basketball
wow
[ __ ] trailer
i'm stealing roller skates
they're bringing me lunch to my [ __ ]
room did these people know i did time
for kidnapping
did they have any idea what i've done
okay
mad tv
spiderman 2 i'm eating lobster tails on
a friday
this is a great life if you pay your
dues but then sag said oh [ __ ] these
[ __ ]
we're going to let you do a movie for
220 000
from now on
so let's pretend
let's pretend stop looking around red
men scared i keep on feeling things you
ain't feeling nothing
it's ants that's [ __ ] comfortable
this guy's cool
let's pretend
you want to do this movie and you come
to me and you go joey i got a perfect
part for you i did it out i hired a
production designer i hired a production
manager it's going to take 9 million to
do the movie
all right i got i i'll ask you what do
you got right now and you'll say i got
1.3 million and i got a guy in germany
that's going to send me 5 million i'll
keep you posted we'll do a table read
we'll shoot a few scenes from it for you
to get the investor money
and then after about a year i won't hear
from red man i'll get a call from red
bank going guess what uncle joey we're
back on you got the role you're the man
you're going to knock it out of the park
oh [ __ ] when do we start we're looking
on october 19th you're gonna work for
six days
only one bad thing what's that
we didn't get the 1.7 million dollars we
needed
we got two hundred thousand six hundred
dollars a day
so this is your glamorous so you go now
i can see
if you're a young actor and you're
learning how to act this is great for
you as an apprentice
but not everybody involved for 100 a day
you figure you got to give your age and
10 bucks commission you got to weigh
your own clothes you really got to know
your way around the set because they cut
on production assistance so it's not
people knocking on your door going lisa
yet
put makeup on you're up next you gotta
pay attention a little more you know
what i'm saying you know do your own
makeup you gotta shave nobody's gonna
take that string out of your
the jacket remember you just saw a
special oswald that had a can you see
that a string coming out of his jacket
are you serious that's what happened
like i only watched 20 minutes of it
because it pissed me off so much on his
right arm he hit a [ __ ] string did he
say anything about it has he publicly
said anything about that string or he's
probably don't bring up the string
i don't know but it's terrible wow
that's embarrassing but you have a
hundred thousand the special so you have
to release it
how did no one notice that because
they're looking at these little monitors
backstage let's see if i can find it
that's what happens on those low budget
production shoots right so the actor
loses everybody loses my thing is if
somebody does the job you [ __ ] pay
him
okay if somebody does the job you pay
him me as a comic i will come to you and
say red man
i'm having a bad month this month get me
started on the podcast and every week
we'll do an hour and a half i'll give
you 25 bucks that's 100 a month that's
something at least we're starting
somewhere 100 these comics won't do that
right they won't even go out their way
they won't even think about it
not to mention that the podcasters that
ate on mondays they show up at 8 25 with
a story
that you know was i answered you're
doing it for free
and it's costing you time yeah
i don't mind doing something for four
weeks for joy to get off his feet right
come on joey get off your feet go go to
that pizza place and tell them that
you'll sponsor you for 100 a week give
me 25. you can even keep 75. people
don't even have that mentality that's a
hustler's mentality you know how can i
have lee over my house in the sun to
help him remove furniture i'm gonna give
him [ __ ] pizza
give him a 50 give him a 50 on the way
out he'll say no give him that 50s gas
money leo love you from now when i call
lee on sundays he'll [ __ ] come my big
beef with those hong kong day movies are
that they make you work sundays
if i made you work for my dream
because that's what this podcast is this
is my dream i come to you as a producer
and i say have an idea we'll play music
at the end i'll stick a kazoo up my ass
you know let's try it's never been done
before whatever the [ __ ] this is what
somebody gives you a shot of your dream
take care of them right it's your dream
so you want me to come on your movie set
on a [ __ ] sunday you're going to give
me the same [ __ ]
mcdonald land [ __ ]
egg mcmuffin you've been giving me all
week go to the diner for 10 bucks extra
get some let's get some scrambled egg
you know what i'm saying there's little
things that go so far when somebody's
doing something for you on a saturday or
sunday this guy's got three kids he's
here for what to help you create your
[ __ ] dream yeah [ __ ] you
and people will do it
until you put your foot down
so from now on every podcast you start
there's a piece of paper when they get
to the podcast going the first three
are free
after that i need 25 bucks i don't care
where you get it from and it's up front
and i'd rather get a hundred dollar bill
at the first of the month just in case
when you get a sponsor figure it out on
your own but i can't keep coming up here
and then that you do the favor like they
said how many times have people come to
us and say i want to do a podcast i'm
gonna get them on the podcast and
they're 20 minutes late
uh that's it you can't i can't work with
you because we're doing this to start up
and you're already [ __ ] up in a 20
minute [ __ ] late so
that's the big thing that burns me i
know you're very generous and i know
you've helped a lot of [ __ ] people
and you know yeah i mean i think that's
what one big part of the the
reconstruction of what i've been doing
lately is just to make it
make more sense to me you know like i'm
not doing the 11 podcast a week anymore
i'm doing you know
what i want to do kill tony i enjoy
doing kill tony uh i saw his chronicles
i enjoy the ice house chronicles once
and joe rogan progress i enjoy joe rogan
price but other than that i used to have
to be like oh i need to do you know four
more shows and do this thing i can't do
that at least right now for a while
until i can figure out a way to
have employees and have people help me
and
and have sponsors and stuff like that
because i mean i'm two math classes away
for having a college degree
and i won't do it because i can't do it
i [ __ ] hate math i hate business i'm
like you know
i probably like you like i look at this
[ __ ] and i'm like i don't know what that
is and i i don't check my mail for uh
every three months now i'll check my
mail take a trash bag empty it into a
trash thing set it down i mean that's
how much i can't deal with that crap you
know
it really [ __ ] sucks
you can't check your mail every three
[ __ ] months all right
you gotta stay on top of this [ __ ]
because if not it gets out of control
you know yeah i'm happy not doing that
many podcasts that just doesn't make
sense it doesn't and the studio it's too
much aspire unless you're doing 20
podcasts on it not you right you're
doing three but somebody else is doing
five and they're giving you three and
that's what that's a part of the whole
thing maybe maybe but then guess what
you're gonna get them as a cheeseburger
yeah somebody left there and that
grandma we just had is now [ __ ] a
half a gram they took the papers and
they took your lighters and your
computer has yeah so at the end of the
week you're like how do i [ __ ]
prosper from this unless it's family
that you trust 150 that listen you see
what this [ __ ] looks like when
you walk in here that's what it's going
to look like when you walk out of here
don't bring no [ __ ] food here you
know you have time slots you got to
write them down you get hit 20 after two
guess what you got a 40 minute podcast
this week you tell that to somebody for
three or four weeks would you stop with
the earthquake
what's up lee syed what do you got
planned this week lincoln this week uh
there you go right there is that another
one yeah are you shaking your feet i'm
not doing i'm just
the water's shaking yeah i think we do
just get another one holy [ __ ]
this is tremendous people
who [ __ ] earthquake we're gonna come
out we're gonna come out it's
yeah something's going on the the
the [ __ ] emails might come in i think
the martians are definitely attacking
yeah earthquake hits los angeles people
it's a beautiful [ __ ] day
rick ramos is going to see fargo and
hudsuck a proxy tonight
she might as well join him
my mom [ __ ] with me she called me the
other week and she was like i was just
talking with my friend the other day
and i was saying even though i live in
new england look at this
see that fly
that fly had birth here he gave birth
that's why there's so many [ __ ] flies
in here that's your [ __ ] fly that you
brought in here so figure it out or
below us there's a dead body
in like in that place but underneath
give birth that's so [ __ ] up
but yeah and then she said i'd rather
deal with snow than deal with
earthquakes just like oh for no reason
to me she loves
earthquakes aren't bad but they're
pretty [ __ ] up that that's a little
worse
was that really enough yeah
we've had two of them i think it must
have been an aftershock
that was you shaking them here
it's all over twitter does it say it
yeah there's been earthquake yeah
yeah
i'll tell you what oh [ __ ] i [ __ ]
love it it's it's a 3.5 3.5 earthquake
and we survived it
live on the church that's how we roll
who the [ __ ] knew there's gonna be an
earthquake we do
we do we're one step ahead of the game
[ __ ] so why didn't we tell
anybody because why would we waste that
time we look like [ __ ] [ __ ]
people say how do you know tell us we
didn't know but we knew that's what i'm
trying to say we didn't know
but we knew why would we have a special
edition
sunday night podcast for our main man
red band if we know but we didn't know
get together
you're [ __ ] slipping [ __ ] i
love that kind of logic we're gonna go
eat tonight i know you're starving i
know you're already thinking that connie
is satisfied in that place on [ __ ] no
i don't i don't cheat here you don't
cheat you i have turkey you know turkey
breast you're gonna go eat that boring
turkey wow how many days old is it like
three oh it stinks no it doesn't yes it
does it's got that little pre-cum on it
yeah yeah three days that's it you gotta
stop and get some new turkey
well that's not gonna happen right now
when you open it up it's got a little
gel like bologna juice like that when
you come in your mouth three days yeah
and it's on your helmet like your helmet
slippery with your fingers
you ever have that i've had that but
that
i've had it i have it right now
where's that turkey that it lasts like
three or four days it lasts but that
thing grows on it you have to eat the
turkey quick that's what they that's why
people buy coke cuts to eat that day
because there's another [ __ ] oh there's
been like eight of them forget it why
are you scaring me
outside my [ __ ] car tipped over
i got [ __ ] maybe like the person that
is out washington running down the
street with a gun
i need this i follow denzel do you
really yeah that's great i i feel like
you get me home safer i'm happy for you
got a second next time you go to mexico
call him correct
see if he'll bail you out what's in the
future for red band what are you
thinking
um
focusing on comedy right now
and trying to get everything back
together
uh i've been doing a lot of uh
home casts lately you know instead of um
podcasting as much if uh if i'm playing
a video game or if i have a friend over
cleaning or something like that we'll
just do like a live stream where we're
not even really paying attention to it
and people still like that [ __ ] so it's
it's it's i'm you know i'm just trying
to figure out what's next uh you know
what
here's in right now while it's a baby
and get my screen name you know because
that's another thing uh that i've found
that everyone has these podcasts now
like if you're the nerdist and a new
program comes out tomorrow you better
make sure you get the nerdist on that
program right the next twitter you want
the next you want your screen name so
i'm constantly trying to figure out
what's next and i i think
it's weird that video games uh podcasts
have blown up so much people people want
to just watch people play video games
nowadays and talk lee's been tormenting
me to start playing video games i just
don't know what i'm doing
i've never played the video you have
this tv now so we could just hook them
up
you can you know uh right i i recently
been a webcam in webcam naming also like
porn webcam
there's this website called chatterbait
no you have it i swear to god uh if you
looked at my twitter avatar last week uh
it was me as my character which i have a
wig on i have this little vest on with
my hairy chest stuff sticking out don't
worry about this and
people tip me i made people online
masturbating to him yeah but i don't get
naked like i'll put lotion on my my my
apples or i'll put some lipstick on or a
chapstick on me or i'll comb my hair
slowly i made the first night and there
was only like 40 people in there i made
120 dollars
but if makeup on
no i didn't put a chapstick i said
chapstick i just put chapstick in the
little on my apples
it's weird so i i i've been doing that
though because that's you know that
killed porn all right uh chat webcams
killed porn that's why porn is not as
popular it's not porn stars anymore
because now like this girl who has a
full-time job in alabama can get on her
you know little webcam when she gets
home and finger herself and make [ __ ]
ten thousand dollars in three hours okay
i have a question how many dollars is a
token
uh you know roughly it's about a dollar
dollar roughly but the the girl only
gets like uh
no it's not i'm sorry 10 tokens are
roughly about a dollar oh okay but the
girl only gets like half of that or
whatever but but i know this one girl i
was watching she made twenty thousand
dollars just
in one hour just people throwing look at
jenna jamison she goes on there it's
like
just tons of [ __ ] money she doesn't
even do [ __ ] she has to be there like or
whatever she does that's so creepy it's
like a virtual strip club no and so what
i've been doing is the reason why i've
been doing this i'm not just doing it
because i'm a [ __ ] creep but i've
been doing it just to see to figure it
out because video gamers are now doing
this they have the same kind of format
where they play games they you get
you pay to subscribe to their channel
you could tip them you know and it's
it's that almost the same formula but
one is playing video games and one is
this so there's something to that where
you're taking taking like the podcast
but you can like have like the you know
a little bit more interactive i think
i don't know i'm just [ __ ] around and
i just don't want an excuse to
i think they should take this workout
the list
of the people who subscribe to those
video game channels and like
go check on them why why would you pay
to watch somebody play video games
and give them a tip huh and then give
them a tip because you know some people
are fun like the hot girls playing video
games is big where they're not getting
naked they're just cute girls playing
video games and uh or kevin pereira that
i used to do a podcast pointless with
he's now doing that where you know he's
making money and and stuff because
people just want to watch and then
they're happy that he's broadcasting and
they can play video games and that's so
creepy it is it is so that's one of the
biggest things i've been just [ __ ]
around with playing video games
and all this stuff just to figure out
if if there's what's there and if
something i might get on video game land
and [ __ ] show them how bad i am it's
getting chased by cars oh i would love
to get you on grand theft auto man i
mean
i'm building a little video game studio
in my living room right now trying to
keep me out of trouble but uh
it's uh it's fun i i bring invite girls
over we just smoke a lot of we play
video games and then you have your voice
in there so you could be like get the
[ __ ] over here and you can reenact you
robbing people and
chasing cops and getting in helicopters
it's fun dude if you if you could figure
it out you would never leave the couch
there's no chance of that happening yeah
that's not a bad idea yeah there's
promise of not leaving the house
that might be in my future
that's what i'm saying [ __ ] going on the
road i'll [ __ ] do family shows in my
closet that's right by myself at [ __ ]
eleven ten nine i don't give a [ __ ] i
think that could happen
that's gonna happen that's gonna happen
those people are talking about it right
now oh this is a service right now but
it just takes
like the ice house you have to wire it's
going to be wired perfect the service
goes down
but they come in they charge an amount
but it was the other company we met with
remember they wanted 50 they said they
were donation marks not that one left
sir yeah lobster they're done right now
they quit yeah
[ __ ] done those people it's it's a
hard racket you gotta have a lot of
people involved in doing it
if you're gonna start that you have to
have a comedy club that has that kind of
like what's that club that steve
whatever
hostile laughs that's the name of the
show on friday and saturday nights on
fox yeah well that's what they're all
scrambling to do right now you know the
improv is building a studio the comedy
store just got internet there you know
where we do kill tony but they they're
building these little studios inside all
these clubs now and that's like a part
of a comedy club now there's a podcast
studio in it you know and it's it's it's
amazing that part of it where you know
these clubs are now broadcasting to
people in germany you know
on some shows so
that's kind of
was that you that was me oh god jesus
christ
that was a big pound one please i got a
[ __ ] size 13
must weigh 82 [ __ ] pounds each foot
like that's right i got a gorilla foot
that's dry with a fungi nail that thing
is a [ __ ] drum yeah what don't you
understand lisa why don't why every
comedy club doesn't have a podcast and
the week before you'd call in and do the
podcast
and that's what that's what makes a
great comedy podcast why don't you come
in have a good meeting you're coming on
thursday you do the podcast at three
and they buy lunch and you do the
podcast or everybody's talking they talk
about you and you sell the week well
most people don't listen live so that
you want to do it like a week out no you
believe in thursday and just like radio
you tape it thursday you release it
friday morning like people come to the
show friday and saturday night yeah but
the issue is people have like a lot of
podcasts people listen to like 20 30
podcasts i think they just they're like
a week behind do you think that's
changed though i mean because i i look
you know people post all the time they
post like their screenshot of what who
they subscribe to on itunes and they tag
me at it or whatever and it used to be
like a shitload of podcasts on people's
lists nowadays it's like it seems like
it's yeah two three well ones have died
but like i didn't even listen to it yet
but that serial thing just happened with
that when that happened with that case
and people are getting into like economy
podcasts they have they show you that
one page people have 40 hours plus let's
say at least two hours commute that's
50 hours a week of time to fill up
and then like i was at the hotel in san
diego this weekend had a nice big tv on
the wall i had my ipad with netflix
so
they don't want to sit and watch
commercials when they're in a hotel
they'll watch a video podcast
so it's just it's uh
[ __ ] i forgot i forgot where i was going
with that but
it's going crazy
i mean look at these porn girls now you
know the cam girls they're doing live
podcasts every single day and they're
[ __ ] themselves on cameras but you
watch half of them aren't even getting
naked they're just sitting there talking
and people are tipping them money why
can't that sing formula be a podcast
that we all love like if they're
watching joey right now and there's
people just like tipping and tipping if
you tip a certain amount you get you
know
you get to eat you have to eat another
thing of weed lee or if you you know tip
this amount then we put their picture on
the wall behind it for a week you know
well the [ __ ] thing is people would
do it yeah but i don't want
people all the time email me ask donate
button
i don't no no that but that's what i'm
trying to figure out i'm trying to
figure out what i'm going to do
when i go to one of these webcam girls i
tip girls on webcams and i want to it's
not me feeling like oh i i'm donating to
them and stuff like no i want them i
feel happy that i tipped that to them
and now they're happy like it's
i need to find that formula for
everybody and that's it's a weird it's a
weird area where you have to you know
look at video game podcasts and then
porn podcasts and
somehow put them together with podca
casting and i don't know it's
interesting to me it's been a tremendous
[ __ ] journey this podcast thing and
lee asked about you know this is the
first time lee came down for the weekend
and we had some time to just chat we you
know we talked about tommy with the with
james in the green room and we that was
really cool and we spoke about just uh
the future and what he thought and what
we've learned you know the marketing
like in the four years i've been doing
the podcast i got my degree in [ __ ]
marketing like this is
this is it we're real we're [ __ ]
college educated podcasters that's it
this is four years this is what they and
this isn't
getting logic or learning theory this is
hands down doing it things blowing up
cameras [ __ ] up you know
this has been great this has been a
great journey and like i said i never
when i did this as you know i was i was
ready to start selling cars i just
wanted to do this as
a shot let's see what we got this is
great you could talk for two hours three
hours and then like i said uh [ __ ] [ __ ]
started making money
corolla
you know and oh i thought i was [ __ ]
off that was that was the beginning of
the end everybody everybody got greedy
we were saying well this guy's making
this this guy's making this so who the
[ __ ] doesn't want to make money to do
this you know and again you know we've
had sponsors contact us and stuff i like
the sponsors we have two or three of
them are just independent people that
we've had on our own the rest of them
are through a company two of them are
through a company
we don't even want the company once
they're the biggest [ __ ] pain in the
ass we just had somebody gonna give us a
ton of lube but it was two hours of work
afterward that they don't need it's all
[ __ ] it's just they're paying you so
they want you to do it just so they have
urls and it's like yeah i don't need to
be here for two hours after the podcast
is over to send you i don't want the
podcast to sound like a billboard you
know i don't mind helping some people
out
so
to me
i'm mid-range still if i didn't have lee
i wouldn't want my money involved in
this thing it'd be like open mics for me
if i didn't have late mm-hmm if i knew
how to do this and lee [ __ ] wanted to
open up his own podcast or
i would you know
i wouldn't care about sponsors i just do
what i'm doing now and i'd be happy
without the [ __ ] bureaucracy and the
[ __ ] yep
and the the checks being laid and they
wrote it to my [ __ ] the name of the
podcast last month we were doing
business for two years they wrote the
checks to the name of the podcast last
you know [ __ ] like that so
yeah i keep on getting the uh my name's
not really redband it's rykel and then
when they book my flights they put under
red van i'm going united here's my
passport i know i'm it says a totally
different last name it's such a pain in
the ass where they write you a check for
with red bands like how am i going to
catch that red band's a fake name
yeah it's annoying right
at least they're writing your [ __ ]
checks yeah brother what do you think
[ __ ] you got anything to say over
there he's gonna sit there thinking
about the turtles tonight what episode
you're gonna watch
and then you got pistachio [ __ ] jello
so you could watch it oh
potato what's pistachio jello oh it's
delicious it sounds great pistachio
first time i tasted pistachio pudding
pudding was in prison it was [ __ ]
delicious with little pistachios and
sometimes i got it now even at the
frozen yogurt chops they got them yeah i
get the pistachio ice cream i love it
when it's green and
some places have baskin robbins that's
what i'm saying the only place i really
have let's get some
sponsors get the [ __ ] out of here as
usual for optimum optimization what is
it lee optimum optimization optimum
optimization you know where the [ __ ]
party starts on it [ __ ]
the best products out there if you want
to [ __ ] make it happen it starts with
alpha brain
money
back guy you don't even want the [ __ ]
product look at that bicep right there
you kidding me that straight up [ __ ]
shroom tech sport and shroom tech
immune i mean listen i was on that way
i'm waiting for a shipment now the tea
stuff
i'm waiting for the coconut oil to put
in my smoothies i'm waiting for some
more
to have protein
it's top-notch he's [ __ ] going in
jungles taking acid he's doing it all to
bring you the best [ __ ] products all
right go to honor.com go to the webpage
honda.com they got the supplement page
they got the nutrients paid see what the
[ __ ] you like
i can't help you with battle ropes and
accessories but i can help you with the
nutrients go to the box and press in
church boom get ten percent off your
first order and if you like it get on
the stay on the program where they send
them to your house every month on the
first of the month all right
now that we're talking [ __ ] apples
and oranges they get down with basics
iron dragon tv you're sitting there at
home there ain't nothing on tv tonight
what the [ __ ] you gonna do sit down like
a jamal tell you what you're gonna do
you're gonna start watching [ __ ]
classic kung fu films go to iron dragon
tv right now they have a tremendous
selection of classic films they got a
honor tutorials they got joe rogan
talking about kettlebells and [ __ ]
the egyptians they got everything on
there what's this called this sounds
awesome iron dragon tv go to iron dragon
tv right now and press in jilly boom and
get two free rentals on the [ __ ] arm
to get your party started mope around
they got great titles if man they got
the hitman series they got everybody out
there patchy hero tai chi hero and they
got new titles and like elise said in
the beginning of the podcast the
innovators and 4k technology so all that
movie is going to be [ __ ] crisp all
right go to iron dragon tv right now and
press in joey boom and get two free
movies you're saying joey i got movies
and i got supplements whatever
what are you gonna do what have you done
for me lately this is what i've done for
you lately [ __ ] let's say you guys
touch him shut up [ __ ] let's say you
got some wax you got a ball of heroin
you want to burn
go to nail the life.com they got a
cracker lacking over there the best
vapor pen on the [ __ ] market and
today only you get 20 off delivered to
your house go to nailed it life.com for
all your dab supplies the stick to put
the [ __ ] grenade on the thing
the cleaner go right now to nail it
live.com look at the selection they got
but if you go with the vapor pen we'll
give you twenty percent off what are
they pressing the box joey diaz boom
twenty percent off delivered right to
your [ __ ] house that's how we roll
and you're going joey but i got no
cigarettes you don't need no [ __ ]
cigarettes [ __ ] here's what you need
hit these things
guaranteed 1200 pups whether you got the
cigar or the cigarette from 24
milligrams to zero that's how they roll
backwards like the ape you understand me
remember the [ __ ] ap turned into a
man that's what happens go to
heavysix.com right now look at the
selection look at the flavors they got
take a look at this [ __ ] cigar
tastes like i'm in cuba right now just
sitting there getting [ __ ] sun on my
face that's how i roll it's yourself go
to hittie6.com right now and press in
joey's church boom joey's church and get
what ladies and gentlemen twenty
[ __ ] percent off so i got you
twenty percent off my head these things
twenty percent off i nailed that life i
got your two free movies mine dragon tv
and i got the ten percent on it
are you [ __ ] kidding me it's not even
pass over and i'm giving you percentages
off
that's how i wrote [ __ ] that's
ever just ended i know lee that's what
i'm saying dog suck it's not even passed
on
thank you red man for coming out yeah
one of the forefathers of podcasting
it's a shame
i hope you get it together and just
don't pop tell these [ __ ] up
front you gotta sign a contract and
that's it
and then if you leave you gotta say you
like your sprint you want 250 on the way
out right
i'll be good is you know the bigger
thing is uh that just getting everything
focused and taking a little break and
that's what i just did so
i'll get it back you're gonna be in
vancouver next monday vancouver 420 like
a [ __ ] four twenty yeah we're
gonna be with tony hinchcliffe we were
there last 4 20 and they have this huge
420 festival where there's kids are
throwing out weed and people are the
cops just like once a year go okay
everyone can just smoke and sell weed
right here and it's like a humongous
party and then at night we do a comedy
show right down the street so it's gonna
be great
yeah just go to desktop.tv click on tour
dates that's why i love your [ __ ] me i'm
gonna be in houston texas
friday and saturday for shows
i don't know 7 39 i don't know what
[ __ ] time call down there
713-333-8800 or something like that will
go on the web page get [ __ ] tickets
and next week i'm at the tempe improv in
tempe arizona
so don't forget about me [ __ ] all
right i love you guys stay black see you
tuesday we'll be here with an all new
[ __ ] tremendous podcast for you thank
you
what lady what are you looking at me all
week
what's up
well they're real earthquakes yes
and i have a new flying jew radio coming
out this week
on wednesday
i'll go to onit.com and use codeword
church to get ten percent off
go to irondragontv.com and use code joey
to get two free rentals of all the great
martial arts movies
go to hit e6 dot com
uh better tasting longer lasting the
proof is in the vape
use code where joey's church to get 20
off your order
and for all the oil and whack smokers
out there go to naildolife.com and use
codeword joey diaz to get 20 off